in the czech republic you can sometimes
see buildings that just
don't really fit the landscape the
city's fabric
sometimes to a comical extent uh
pictured here is a street
uh an old street to the left which just
kind of ends
and gives away to this big empty space
and then
this space is closed off by a big gummy
block there are
a great number of examples like this and
turns out there's a reason for it
that reason being deliberate and planned
barbarism speaking of which let's talk
about czechoslovakian city planning
from the 50s and 60s onwards
czechoslovakian city planners had the
same ideas as pretty much everyone else
in
europe and america these ideas were
basically that cars are the future
cities must accommodate cars above all
pedestrians should be separated from car
traffic mainly through underpasses
but also other methods public
transportation was imagined as a mix of
metro
bus and maybe trolleybus trams were
considered obsolete
and fit for removal and the metro was
supposed to be the big backbone
complemented by smaller bus lines or 20
lines maybe
and of course this entire system was to
be framed by a system
of urban highways a particularly
atrocious example is the prague
magistrala which is an urban freeway
that basically just cuts the city in
half and not only does it do that
it creates this weird island around the
national museum among other things but
we're not here to talk about prague but
a city
called ustinadlabem formerly ozig
which is halfway between prague and
dresden its population is about 90 000.
uh used to be a big industrial center
in the north of the czech republic up
until the velvet revolution
the regime change and the subsequent
collapse of industry
and this was the place where the
czechoslovakian leadership
just really went all out with their city
planning ideas
which can only be characterized as
extremely
bizarre so let's recap some of ustia's
history
it was a historical industrial center
since the austro-hungarian monarchy
that's the 19th century
this brought in a lot of workers the
industries
mostly germans and in the beginning i
mentioned that it was called aussie
and that's because it was basically a
german city up to the second world war
in the 1930 census the city had 43
793 residents of which
32 878 were german 8735 or czech or
slovak
222 jews 16 russians and 11
fellow compatriot hungarians in 1938 of
course the city was taken over by the
nazis
and towards the end of world war ii the
city was taken back by advancing soviet
forces
but the point where the city changed
forever basically
was the summer of 1945 where the
so-called usti massacre happened when an
ammo depot exploded killing around 27
people
seven of whom were czechs and this
somehow triggered a massive lynching of
germans in the city
the official number of victims ranged
from 80 to 120
but some estimates go all the way to 4
000 which is most likely overshooting it
the psychosis was so incredible that at
one point a mother and her baby
were thrown into the albert from a
bridge and then shot at by soldiers
and after the revolution it turned out
that this whole thing was actually
orchestrated by the czechoslovakian
secret service to make a better case for
the explosion of germans
into germany in which they succeeded and
the vast majority of the city's original
population was just basically uh
deported
so here we are after the war in the 50s
60s
the industry is being rebuilt new
residential complexes are being erected
and new people are being shipped in the
war didn't damage the city as much
the overwhelming majority of the city
fabric is still undamaged
so what was the czechoslovakian
leadership's idea for urban planning
they wanted to turn using alabama into a
model city
with all the latest innovations in
planning and shine new architecture
in practice this mostly meant styles
such as soviet modernism and brutalism
and of course your average blocks of
flats the plan was to move people
and mass to large residential areas
around the center
and turn the center itself into an
exclusively governmental slash
commercial district
with brand new architecture the only
problem was that the city was already
there
and in such cases you can't really make
big changes and you shouldn't either
unless it's absolutely necessary so the
czechoslovakian government said
okay and then they just started blasting
entire blocks were just completely
leveled
this meant blowing up multiple dozens of
buildings
including most of the main street only
to be built back up with grey blocks
and turns out these architectural styles
don't really age too well especially if
they aren't maintained
so half the main street was essentially
leveled which meant blowing up
19 apartment buildings simultaneously
which is an all-time record in a country
for this they had to custom design a
demolition switch that had twice the
capacity of the best devices at the time
able to detonate 20 000 demolition
charges at the same time
so in 1980 half the main street was
blown up but the leadership was just
getting started the strikov district in
particular
an entire neighborhood called kremlin
was leveled the plots of which have not
been built up to this day
now there's a couple of giant open
fields
instead of you know housing for people
according to the original plans
in the city center only the church and a
bank building were to remain
that's two buildings in total everything
else was planned to be demolished
eventually
but thankfully most of these plans could
not be realized due to a
lack of money this is how the main
street's second half was saved by the
way they just ran out of money
that being said large-scale demolitions
went on all the way until 1989
the revolution and in some cases
continue to this day
all the way in a smaller scale
thankfully for example next to the
zapaninadhraji train station
these two and a half blocks are mostly
gone by now
here's a picture i took a few days ago
as you can see
most of the buildings are gone with the
rest are also sort of slated for
demolition
and looking at google street view these
buildings
weren't in such a bad shape i mean of
course they were like
completely neglected and not maintained
but these are massive
brick apartment buildings i mean these
these things aren't just gonna fall down
as far as i know most of the buildings
were structurally sound
the buildings were bought by a local
politician slash businessman
who planned to turn them back into
apartment buildings
but this of course never happened so
instead what we're gonna get here is a
lidl
instead of you know housing and not just
any housing
i mean these plots literally overlook
the future site of the high-speed rail
station
on the prague dresden high-speed railway
oh and by the way
on these empty plots i showed you
earlier in struck off guess what's going
to be built here
a little so i don't know if there's a
conspiracy going on
between little and the city but it's
strange to say the least
so after the revolution the megalomaniac
plans were axed of course
but as the industry declined the city
was faced with a new problem
that needed urban planning solutions
namely the situation with the roma who
were mostly
forcibly relocated from slovakia to do
unskilled labor in the local factories
but of course the industry collapsed and
with it the facade of order that the
czechoslovakian leadership put up
throughout the years
and all these social problems came
bursting up like a volcano essentially
mostly with the local roma community
problems included poverty
lack of opportunities low level of
education high crime rates and so on
this situation lasted for years while
the local government was essentially
doing nothing to address these issues
you know from a city planning
perspective when an area is at risk of
becoming a ghetto
uh what you do there is uh launch social
programs uh make sure kids attend school
properly you help train people for
getting new jobs maybe even buy out some
of their homes and help them relocate
or you know increase police presence in
the area but since the affected people
were roma
of course none of this happened and
instead their neighborhoods were just
basically left to rot with all kinds of
social problems very quickly spiraling
out of control
so when problems became unbearable in
one particular neighborhood
the city decided it's time to do
something finally in the form of
building a
two meter tall 150 meter long wall
to separate roma residents from non-roma
and this is the equivalent of me coming
home and
noticing that the bedroom is on fire so
i just lock its door and go to sleep in
the living room
the offense stood for a grand total of
five weeks after which it was torn down
due to public pressure
uh even vaslav pavel himself came to
usti to handle the situation
after this fiasco the city was given
some grant money to help solve the
social problems
but they went ahead and used this money
to buy out the apartments of the
non-roma in the area
and essentially evacuating them out thus
creating aroma only ghetto
so their strategy is basically to ignore
social problems and let them run for a
while and then just
[ __ ] about it so let's check with
slovakian urban planning for you
what really astounded me during my
research for this video is the almost
sociopathic
negligence of the authorities both for
the built environment and for the people
and honestly i don't think i've ever
seen destruction of historical buildings
on this scale outside the u.s
but hopefully ustin alabama will become
a lesson for future urban planners
one can only hope anyway thanks for
watching and if you have a historic city
center
please don't blow it up
[Music]
you